ladies and gentlemen we got a great show
tonight we're gonna that oh I'm sorry
it's my uber kick app your uber kick app
yeah it's like uber but for talk-show
sidekicks
anytime someone needs me I get pinged
it's you know helps me earn some extra
money you're earning extra money as an
uber sidekick yes I'm earning extra
money as an uber sidekick and somebody
needs me so do you mind I just gotta
take this one
yeah fine even brings his own podium
that's amazing come on Karen it's like
you told the farmer you wanted a bull
and he up and sold you a cab oh I'm
sorry I gotta go I got another call
hey listen don't worry about it I'll
give you five stars thanks so much hey
good luck with your problem
[Music]
[Applause]
which go on while you were yup ended up
with dr. Phil I hired a new sidekick
Hannibal Buress
you see Andy you're not the only one who
uses uber sidekick shusui that are out
there and I'm pretty amazing look at
that
no Burris is there there's Robert Durst
the murderer ha ha good one boss that
mat was real funny yeah it's ass
Hannibal you're the best you're great
pleasures all mine
hey can I'm into one thing boss sure
sure you can't Hannibal go ahead I'm
hosting the 19th annual Webby Awards on
Monday May 18th you can watch it the
next day on demand at webby awards calm
man I can't wait to watch that that's
gonna be wait to watch it you two make
me sick get off my stage you homewrecker
fine with me I don't even like it here
[Applause]
from the new believe pound of flesh
legendary actor jean-claude van damme is
here
[Applause]
CW series The Vampire Diaries Nina
Dobrev zon the sir
we go get the word yeah
take a break we'll be right back stick
around Jimmy go